okay so just a heads up before we get
started that this video
is a little heavier than what you're
used to seeing from this show
so if you came here looking for some
upbeat esports news
this is not the video for that but it's
an important story
and we felt it was important to report
on it a 19 year old brazilian call of
duty mobile player
was killed on february 22nd near sao
paulo brazil
she was allegedly repeatedly stabbed to
death by another local call of duty
player
here's the whole story
back on february 22nd brazilian police
allege that guillermo
alves costa who goes by flashlight in
cod mobile
killed ingrid oliveira bueno de silva
who goes by saul in-game costa allegedly
stabbed da silva multiple times with
both
a knife and a sword the incident took
place in piratuba which is a
neighborhood
near sao paulo this information comes
from a report from the public ministry
of the state of sao paulo in brazil
as well as a formal police report both
in portuguese
which we had translated in-house here at
the score the body was found by local
police on tuesday february 23rd
the next day the same day that costa
confessed
both costa and da silva were call of
duty mobile players
da silva played for a team called fbi
esports
and costa played for gamers elite so far
in the legal proceedings an indictment
has been filed against costa
charging him with first degree murder
for vile reason and use of cruel means
after the initial news broke two videos
surfaced on youtube that appear to show
costa confessing to the crime those
videos have since been taken down
we translated the videos in the first he
appears to confess to the crime
and says that he did it because he
wanted to in the second video
he addresses those who thought the
arrest was fake or that it wasn't him
and asserts that it was him and again he
committed the murder because he wanted
to
now according to the police report da
silva's family came to the police
station
but were unable to provide any further
details about the relationship between
da silva
and costa that said more details have
come out about the potentially
premeditated nature of the crime
according to a statement from gamer's
elite that we translated
costa recorded a video of the murder and
sent it to the gamers elite whatsapp
group on the 22nd
the day that it happened gamer's elite
also said that kosta sent the group
a 52-page document filled with what they
described as hate messages against
christians that incited a hate crime
then a brazilian
english literature professor and also a
feminist blogger
named lola aranovich says that kosta
sent her an email
after the fact with the subject line
quote
commendable act aranovich said that the
email linked to several videos of the
murder
and also promised more attacks she was
also sent the same 52-page document that
gamer's elite was sent
in the document that cost ascent to both
iranovich and his whatsapp group
which the score has acquired he
describes a quote
strong hatred for women end quote that
has developed over the past few years
he also says that the murder was not
vain and that he intends for people to
quote learn from it according to a
follow-up blog post by ronovich she
received a phone call and an email with
more threats on february 24th aranovich
alleges that the caller threatened to
kill her
if she didn't remove mention of a
misogynist online forum
similar to 4chan called crazychan
from her blog on february 28th aranovich
tweeted that she received another phone
call
claiming that quote guillermi was just
the beginning and quote
other attacks will come aronovich also
said that she received an email that
same day
february 28th with photos of another
woman dead in gravada brazil
now the first place that many members of
the english-speaking world
saw the news was a statement from
another brazilian esports organization
called jaguars gigi
here's the translated statement quote it
is with immense sadness that jaguars
esports
sends condolences and strength to saul's
family members and to fbi esports team
we are all in mourning may you rest in
peace and may justice prevail
end quote another esports organization
in brazil called battlegirls tweeted
this statement
quote my dear friends our team player
saul was brutally assassinated
we wanted to be more sensitive about
this topic but we are in shock
she disappeared for a few days and was
found murdered by a psychopath
who stabbed her to death recorded it and
posted it on social media
hence we will be in mourning for 24
hours end quote
after that initial jaguar's thread
esports personality slasher tweeted the
news in
english and teams and personalities from
around esports
started to share support for da silva
and her family now
as for the case against costa itself
according to the police report that
we've acquired
he's been charged with first degree
murder and brazilian authorities are
seeking
a maximum sentence with no opportunity
for bail in the coming days he'll be
heard by a judge
and a jury in brazil to determine
sentencing
[Music]
you